okay well here with me now to discuss
the latest developments in ukraine ed
arnold a former british army officer and
a research fellow for european security
at the royal united services institute
ed hello again um so what's what's
currently happening in kharkiv and in
the surrounding areas there and how is
that affecting donbass
yeah so in terms of kharkiv i mean the
battle is effectively over and ukraine
has won and it's further evidence the
russian military really are going to
struggle to take any of the large
population centers it's the second
largest city and what ukrainian forces
have been able to do is put in a very
effective counter-attack which has
pushed ukrainian field artillery out of
range of the city but also actually
pushed russian forces back to the border
as you can see in the yellow hashed area
at the top of the screen and that's
going to cause significant issues for an
already challenging offensive for russia
within the donbass from russian
perspective uk defense intelligence
overnight estimated that one third of
their ground forces have now been
destroyed or in combat and effective
within ukraine itself that's significant
due to the fact it's heavy losses but
also russia will really struggle to
replenish those forces both in terms of
people because that's politically very
difficult for president putin he needs
to mobilize but also they're just
running low on armored vehicles tanks
and especially ammunition as well so the
main effort is assessed is still from
belgrade in the north to israel that is
the main axis of advance and that is
really the arterial route where russian
forces are resupplying the offensive
down to the south what's actually having
happened to happen at the moment is
russian forces are switching from the
offensive to the defenses because they
need to protect that line so ukraine
have a couple of options the first
option which is the safest option is to
put a ring of steel around kharkiv and
make sure that it is protected it's
still close to the russian border and
still vulnerable secondly they might
redeploy forces south to join the
counter-offensive in issue in which you
are expecting to start proper in the
next couple of days and that high-risk
high reward strategy is really to
actually press east and really try and
disrupt and basically dislocate that
line of communication which will really
put a
real pressure on the russians here and
the russian objective was still to
capture the whole of donbass but because
of the way that this war was being
prosecuted at this point it's probably
going to be a smaller area around
several donetsk which they're able to
capture
okay okay so um what's happening in the
south and the west of the country
yeah so also in the south one of the
objectives is for russia to control the
whole coast and access to the black sea
and really critically what we're seeing
in curse on almost mirrors what's
happening in the east at the moment we
know that there is a russian intent to
move from curson west all the way over
to moldova and the strip of land on the
east which is transgenistria and then it
essentially links
russia in the east all the way to
transition that's 330 kilometers and at
the moment on the issum offensive their
main effort they're only moving about 3k
a day in their best areas so that's
quite a difficult proposition militarily
and ukrainians are putting in a very
effective counter
attacks south amiculi have which is
stopping that advance and then
politically also in kursan it's an area
that russia wants to hold a referendum
to join the russian federation they were
trying to do it last month and now
ukrainian intelligence suggests that
they've had to push back those plans
until september so it's a real area
which we're focusing on curse on because
that's ultimately going to be the test
case of whether they can turn political
military objectives in terms of holding
the ground into political objectives
which is the control of the ground
okay fascinating ed thank you very much